he says Lawton Ibrahimovic he plays for
the LA Galaxy back on the program
and joins us now I hear you're getting
treatment right now are you done I was
getting treatment but not to start
because I wanted to talk to you so you
come in first hand you come before my
body so I like that when when you wake
up in the morning what hurts
everything everything I'm in the age
where everything hurts in my body so I
need a lid at least two three hours to
get it on how long ago did you have your
big knee surgery that was in April last
year so one year and a couple of months
did you think your career was over no
never
impossible I decide when it's over how
bad was it was very bad I had an injury
that that normally you don't come back
from it's not because it's me now and it
happened to me but I had a multi multi
injury in the knee so it was not one
thing it was like three four things and
it was it was complicated but I said to
myself I don't want to stop like this I
decide how to work out and when it's and
when it's finished do you think if you
didn't have that knee surgery you might
still be playing in the Premier League
no I think I would it would be the same
path but the only difference would be
that I would be on the pitch and not
outside the pitch so they're lucky I was
on the side for one year I saw you run a
motorcycle the other day is that it is
there new players no I
yeah the bike is new but I have some
bites in Sweden I'd like to go around
drive and just to cruise around these
nice fresh hair
what kind of bikes do you know I have I
have three three holiday with some we
rode muscle what do I have a night fold
special edition and now I have a
breakout Harley ok what
pretty good that you can drive and then
nobody knows at you yeah with the helmet
is difficult to see Who I am so that
maybe I should walk around with a helmet
what's the what's the oddest place
you've ever been recognized when I was
in a ski resort so I was in this lift on
my way up to the mountain and I have
these googles helmet and I have this how
do you say the next thing you have
around your neck so I'm like hiding
everything and when I'm sitting in the
lift with my wife a little guy turns to
the right and he says Ibiza Ebola and
I'm pretending like I'm not hearing and
we go on and he goes like e blah blah
and I like I have to turn around and I
was like how did this little boy
recognize me and I think it was the nose
recognize the note because that was the
only thing I could not hide great
can you clear this up because last time
you're on you said if you weren't
married you'd be spreading your seed
around the United States to help Team
USA so we could develop some soccer
playing how did that go over with your
wife when did you tell her or did she
know that if she was like you think you
were funny or not I was being serious
because that was perfect
okay but how about a slot on sperm bank
no I don't share myself with like that
my wife she's the only one who get my
investment okay I have two two ninjas at
home and that's enough for the moment
wait they're ninjas yeah I tried to
raise them like ninja have you gotten
used to LA traffic yeah I mean I'm not
driving around the traffic I'm flying
around so I avoid all the traffic wait
there's lot on have a helicopter no but
me I don't work I'll fly I didn't know
okay the traffic is okay the only
difference is that they're lousy drivers
never not to drive car in LA that's the
only difference well how would you
compare them to you've been in Barcelona
Milan Paris Manchester the traffic is
going like in one rhythm here when it
stops it stops but even when it goes
there lousy drivers here
I think they should redo all the driving
license just like I did and I passed it
what did you think of Renault no going
to your ventas I think is good is good
for the Italian football me myself I
played in Italy but I was in Italy when
the when the championship was at top was
the best in there in the world and then
it went down because a lot of players
went away from Italy and now him coming
there I think is fantastic for the
Italian football and you went to me I
played there so it's one of the best
clubs in the world so he's in the right
place if he if he wants to play in Italy
so I'm happy for for the Italian
football and for your ventures
especially because they're doing big
things
how what was the bet you had with David
Beckham with the World Cup the bet was
if Sweden wins I get to buy whatever I
want some care but if they lose I hope I
would have to go to Wembley to eat fish
and [ __ ] and to watch again in English I
owe him that I should send the whole
Sweden team with the England shirt and
towards the game it's pretty exciting
stuff now
yeah was nice was good was good because
we didn't had a good run in the World
Cup and even England was good were you
rooting for Croatia at all I mean my
mother's question I don't know if people
even know that but my mother's Croatian
my father's Bosnian and and I'm Swedish
you see what kind of mix it is crazy but
but I would it would be nice to see
questio win because I mean the countries
like for 5 million people living there
and have a fantastic team like that it
would be nice because they're a
fantastic worker are you
interested in the Lakers this year or
the LA Rams I don't know so much about
the LA Rams but about Lakers I think I
will go and what was the game's
absolutely
have you met LeBron no no no how about
we put him in goalie
LeBron no I would put him as uh as a
striker really and I and I would put
myself just behind him so I serve him
and you just finish the word but you are
curious about that I mean there's a
whole phenomenon I don't know what you
would relate this to in in your sport
but LeBron coming to Los Angeles is you
know the biggest sport story of the year
I think so it's a big thing I mean
coming is one thing then you need to win
when you come that makes it even bigger
just like he did it is when he went back
to the Cleveland yeah it would be it
would be nice to see how are my Galaxy
doing my galaxy is doing great even if
we lost the last game but before that we
had like eight nine games in row without
losing so we are getting the points we
need and we're coming slowly but we were
setting the pieces together there's a
difference between basket and football I
have to take care of ten players the
money has to take care of four players
you got Minnesota coming up on Saturday
it's always great to catch up with you
Slaton thank you and good luck for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]